all right hi my name is dr. Neil singer
and I'm the president and CTO of AC
kinetics and I'll be talking about using
system modeler to rapidly build and
verify Hardware control systems so give
you an executive summary while we'll be
talking about here the give you a little
talk about what AC connects does and
then we'll talk about our use of system
modeler and I'll present two usage cases
one will be a two dimensional tilting
table demonstration how many people have
seen that downstairs just about
everybody okay great if you haven't you
go down and see it
and that I'll talk about modeling that
system constructing the hardware and
then the image processing software and
integration with system modeler the
second case is is what we actually do in
that was an intern project and so that
was not our commercial activity but I'll
actually talk about what we do
commercially and that's our our second
case and that's the developing testing
and verifying real-time software in
system modeler and I'll talk about our
motor drive hardware that's what and how
we model it and then our use of system
modeler and in the testing and verifying
that and then I'll show some data that
we've actually collected using the this
that you know using the system so first
who is AC kinetics well we're an
independent engineering and motion
control design and development company
were based out of our mock New York
we're just that's just north of that's
just north of of New York you can tell
them from New York because even though I
left my jacket off I'm still one of the
most overdressed president presenters
here anyway the the
were a bunch of MIT PhD scientists
engineers developers working together
for 25 years and we've been doing a lot
of machine control and vibration control
work over that time our initial
technologies that I worked on in the in
the 90s was residual vibration reduction
for motorized equipment
one of our we've done some work with a
no sway crank control that's used to for
systems that load nuclear fuel rods into
into reactors as well as other
applications and Industry we worked on
hard drives improving a disk drive
rewrite times and acoustics and
developed and what we'll be talking
about in our current products as we
develop proprietary non-linear
optimization technology that for dynamic
systems and that technology we then used
to develop an AC induction motor control
that saves energy so that's kind of the
background
oh and recently we entered into a joint
development agreement with koch
industries and so we've teamed up with
them in order to commercialize this
technology here's some of our previous
licensees and ok so the first project
was done by bus every year I run an
internship program at my at my at the
company bottom Hills High School in our
mock New York has a program called
senior explorations a six weeks
internship it's a six-week program for
all high school seniors everybody has to
do it it's required and usually the
engineering guys come over and call me
so I take in a group of engineers
they're all you know really excited
engineers I have two of them here
actually Micah and prana so you can see
the list so so Micah Jiang is currently
here at UIUC that's why you'd have to
walk very far Jordan Lavinia is at SUNY
at SUNY Binghamton math Schwimmer is at
Cornell and prana off year as well front
up is also currently at UIC so it did
pretty well I got two of two of them
came here of course I take credit for it
but they got in before they started
working with me so I can't take too much
credit for it so and and and and and I
was their supervisor along with Arturo
as one of my engineers and so what they
built was a system that looks like this
it if you you go to the base when you
can see it it's a labyrinth game it's a
wooden platform you can buy them for you
know 15 bucks at 12 bucks on Amazon
something like that you know it's a
wooden toy basically and they added some
some $5.00 servo motors to it and turned
it into a 2d table which is a great way
to you know for low-cost an Arduino runs
it if you look over here the you know
the QSB camera looks at where the the
marble or the but the other ball the
little metal ball is located it have a
vision program that's written in Java
that that processes that information
sends it to system modeler and here's
the Arduino and then that and that feeds
back to the to the system so let's just
take a quick look at it running and you
can see that's me pushing on it with a
piece of pipe and you can see the thing
you know the ball the vision camera is
up here the USB camera is watching where
the ball is located you can see in the
screen in the back the vision program is
processing the location of the ball and
putting it back to to the center and
that is running downstairs in case
anybody missed it so and this is the
video with it that was done yet the
first day when we had the black ball now
an orange ball there because we noticed
an usual situation is when people stood
around that the shadows would confuse it
for black so I changed the color to
orange and threw an orange ball in so
anyway so in that modelling the system
now this part I did this part just to
get them started it's just shown that
you can model this is a cool feature
system modeler this I actually did a
quick model and system modeler of the
ball and I get an animation out of it so
I was able to build it with built-in
components in system modeler and I'll
show the model and then it's it's
actually controlling it to go around in
a square and that's it's running a
controller is a PID controller it's
feeding back the position of the ball
and it and so so we get a nice little
animation you can sort of test what
you're doing and just to show you what
that actually looks like this is the
model and so we have if I go through it
the the input here is a table lookup
table and X and X is
save X's in put the in the corner there
is not used it's for inputting noise so
if you want to simulate the real not
real feedback noise I can throw some
noise in there we have some jitter and
come and put some you know that normal
distribution of noise or some other
distribution of noise which is I did do
just to test my controller out then you
have a PID loop a PID block that's
built-in sampling it so he sampled the
feedback so at 30 times a second because
that's what the frames of the video is
doing is 30 times a second and that runs
then the 2d model and I'll show you what
the 2d plate model looks like that's a
little more complicated because I wanted
to get the animation in there if I
didn't want the animation it would be
easier actually in this case it was
easier to do it with the animation
because the dynamics of a 2d ball are
not simple that's actually really
complicated so by using the built-in
components it made it it made it
dynamically accurate
I mean I'll walk through real quick
because I don't spend a lot of time
here's a filter that just filters it so
them so it mimics the real hardware more
accurately and then it's a rotation
command so it converts this number into
rotation command there's a rotational
joint in in an X and in Z for the plate
and that just gives the picture of the
plate that you saw then we have some
motion in Z but the motion in Z is not
unconstrained motion it's constrained
motion it constrains it by this rolling
constraint to the rotation in Z and it's
constrained by the de the radius of the
ball and that all feeds comes back round
here's the ball the graphics of the ball
and a position sensor and in a frame
that's rotating on the ball so by doing
this I know that I have a dynamically
accurate model of the ball and I get an
animation for free so that's why I
thought that was a good way to do it
so then what the students did is took
that and converted into a hardware model
this is the hardware model they it's the
same same thing same PID controller
basically but that a retune it there's a
dead band in there just so when it gets
close it stops and then what does the
actual model look like that's running
and it's really simple that's what's so
cool about system eilers you know it
doesn't take a lot of blocks it doesn't
take a lot
components there's a coordinate
transformation going on in here so that
the coordinate frame of the video is
changed to the coordinate frame of the
motors just so you've got you know you
have that correct and if you notice
right here pin 9 is the pin 9 of is the
output this is the art of Arduino and
then pin 9 of the Arduino hooked up to Z
and pin 10 of the Arduino sucked up to X
and that's the whole thing so we know
that anything happening going on pin 10
will go out get output to the to the
servo motor will determine the servo
motor position in in X so the now the
image the one of the interesting parts
of this is the extent is the image
processing I was lucky that my Co
happened to do science research using
open CV and image processing so that's
one of the reasons they picked this
project is someone actually knew it
already so they knew a lot of the they
knew the code on it so anyway so he
wrote a standalone Java program and ran
open CV routines to capture the image
frames process the camera image identify
the location of the ball and then
compute the midpoint of the ball and
then what we did to that with those who
take those coordinates and how to send
it back to system model and this is one
of the cool features of system modeler
is that system modeler from the ground
up was built to be controlled by tcp/ip
commands once the program systems
simulation center talks to the model to
the running standalone model it does so
through TCP IP packets you can take that
standalone model and you can run it
anywhere you can run on any computer it
gets you get the source code you can
move the source code wherever you want
and compile it however you want but the
nice thing is it does talks tcp/ip to
with whatever you want in our case we
used it for feedback we could have also
just made a panel like a for tuning
games we could have done live tuning of
games with a tcp/ip panel and to show
you how to do that it's really not that
hard this is the code that's all--that's
the code for sending the packets the
first line creates a string with the
command user input values is one of the
system model or built-in commands X is
what's the variable we want to change
and user inputs the value that was
computed
above by the vision program the hex
string is some header my only critique
of system allopatric don't take it
personally was that wasn't that wasn't
documented so I had he with the students
gotta use a packet sniffer to figure out
what the packets were and and back
reverse-engineer it from the from what
it was from what simulation center was
sending so I kind of stole the you know
the packet and and then and then it
figured out how to create it so we had
to put all that those those hex strings
had to be there I'm not sure what they
all mean and and then the packet lengths
and then converted to ASCII and send it
out and flush it and that's it to do it
in C because I actually wrote it first
and see I'm not a Java programmer that's
it in C same kind of thing you do an S
printf put it in the buffer
you know reproduce those ASCII those hex
header header codes and and and then
convert it all and then do a write to
the socket you have to I don't show the
opening of the socket but I can always
post that code Patrick if you're if they
if they want it on the website I'm sorry
oh no I just wrote the packet tester in
see Micah was writing the program in in
Java and Mike and Pranav and the other
guys were right right so those guys were
doing Java but I didn't see first
because I wanted to see I I didn't
really know Java very well then let's
say we got okay so now let's say the
second case won't we that was a great
intern project that they did a great job
on it by the way if anyone's hiring
interns they're right here local so you
guys have to - awesome candidates
that's the shameless plug here that
we're putting in any way but and any
actual four of them are great students
so there'd be any one of them would be
wonderful so uses case - we develop and
test a used system modeler in our actual
workflow which is why I wanted the
students to use it when they came to
work with us so what do we do
I developed a nonlinear optimization
based algorithm that
optimize the magnetic fields and
resulting high efficiency for AC
induction motors so we developed this
control architecture that utilizes the
existing power converters capabilities
deliver optimize performance while
improving that energy efficiency and we
then successfully deployed it so just
quick thing about why does anyone care
about induction motors because probably
most people here don't really know much
of Adam it turns out that 45% of the
world's electricity winds up going into
these things
okay that's forty five percent of all
the electricity produced everywhere in
the world it's done and they're used in
pumps are used in materials handling
they're used in HVAC the fans that that
carry the air in this building these
motors are everywhere and so they're
using a lot of in an industrial
application that's even higher at sixty
to seventy percent because in consumer
applications we use less so the other
thing that's interesting is that ninety
percent of the cost of a motor system is
its energy so you can afford to spend a
lot more money on a better motor on a
better Drive because you're spending the
money and the energy over the life of
that of that have that drive so this is
a prototype that we put together it's
not for sale it will never be for sale
we were right now teamed up with coke
industries and we're licensing the
software to drive makers this drive is
used for our testing and for
verification and validating the software
it's a beast it takes 600 volts as its
input and it puts out 900 amps at it's
at its peak it's enough to melt a Tesla
you can it wouldn't run continuously at
that but it certainly can do a 400 horse
motor if it wanted to you know the and
so the problem is is that with that kind
of power available it's dangerous to put
software in there that's going to be
controlling this thing and not knowing
if it's going to work so what we do is
we test it so we test it and we assist a
modeler to test it so the first thing we
do is we'll run our C code in system
modeler run a simulation to verify it
and then we'll turn around and we'll run
the same software in our hardware now
obviously refused and we have other
issues you know we have other
actions in place and software
protections but what's really cool here
is we use the exact same C code in
system modeler that we use in the drive
it doesn't change there's not a line of
code that changes okay it is exactly the
same and so we poured it from one to the
other we check it out of the repository
and it goes into one we check it out of
the repository and it goes into the
other so this is the model this is a
model where I'll run with them with the
motor code again so here's an AC
induction motor inertia some damping
torque and a tort and a torque profile
that we want to we want to test over
here we have our digital controller
that's our C code we have an input for
what we have to ramp input for the speed
and we over here's just a digital clock
that's our servo rate for it right now
this one happens to be running at 4
kilohertz so it's saying run at 4
kilohertz we have our inverter that
changes the the commands from the
software into into n 2 voltages and that
guns a three-phase motor to show what's
what's going on inside the controller
block that's the code that's all the
code system all our code I don't know if
people know the delica language but
basically says those are my inputs those
are my outputs it's an external C code C
function
there's the calling sequence and the
annotation tells you where it's located
where they include directories and what
file you're including that's it that's
what brings in all our C code and when
we create and system modeler will then
run it and it will actually merge our
code in with their code compile it and
create a fully running fully running
executable out of that entire package we
can then take that and move it somewhere
or just run it and use system ollars
features to to do it this is an example
in the real world where we're using our
drive to say yet I don't know if I know
Brian last night got an award from a
georgia-pacific is here yep not here T
must be late left the and he works this
is actually at the georgia-pacific we
worked with the people there to do a
test this is on a hard tile winder so
configure the motor
to replicate this winder it's a 60 horse
motor 92% efficient its and we went to
as Miss certified laboratory to test it
the and we completed lab tests using the
actual so went the field we measured the
torque the speed of the motor the
inertia and that's all you need really I
mean a motor doesn't know anything other
than torque speed inertia that's all
it's that's all it knows right it
doesn't know anything about what machine
it's hooked up to so what we did is we
measured the torque the speed and we and
we in the inner and the inertia and we
went to laboratory and we duplicated all
that and that's what we gave the motor
so then we compared that to the to the
to the to the production towel winder
here's the actual winding machine it's
pretty it's a big beast a 60 horse motor
it's running a six foot by said that
roll looks like a small little roll it's
actually six foot diameter and six feet
long that just gives you a perspective
on how how large this thing is it's a
say it's making the rolls that you find
wine in the in the restrooms on those
machines that roll towel out here's the
profile it will roll up accelerate up
roll the towel accelerate down to a
slower speed those are our PM's and and
it transfers to the set the next roll
and then it speeds up again this thing
never stops 24/7 and so basically what
do we do is our technology saves half
the energy in this particular machine
that's a big number
most applications will not be that large
but it's a particularly dynamic
application so compared to the drive
they're actually using it saved half the
energy and just give you the savings was
$24 annual savings if we don't change
the drive and just change the software
it would be an instantaneous payback if
you actually change the drive it would
be under three years would be thirty
month and that just shows the
temperature I'm only one more slide and
I'll take questions and that's just
showing the temperature of the you know
using our technology versus the other
and we've simulated these and we have
very similar results in the simulation
from the system modeler plots not just
showing the reduced heat lower
temperature and that's pretty much it I
can take questions you know on any of
that thank you
you